hey everyone the new Riverdale trailer
is here no thanks saying it's not yes
chilling Adventures of Sabrina part
three is just a few weeks away and
netflix has decided to post a trailer
within a music video and if this trailer
is any indication we are in for the
darkest season yet I'm not gonna spend a
lot of time discussing the music video
part because I want to get right into
the juicy stuff from the show so let's
go straight to hell and see what we can
find of course the title of this trailer
is a reference to where we left off in
part 2 let's go to hell and get my
boyfriend back with Nick scratch having
sacrificed himself to contain Lucifer it
looks like Sabrina and the gang will
spend much of this chapter focusing on
how to save Nick and stop the Lord of
Darkness for good we see Nicky are
wrapped in chains symbolic of being
trapped and I'm not sure what I can say
about this but bold move Harvey bold
move here is prudence caressing the back
of Ambrose suggesting further romance
between the two now we get into some of
the actual clips from part three sabrina
is searching for a book likely in a
forbidden part of the witch Academy
which if you remember aunt Zelda is now
High Priestess of we get a few shots of
Nick imprisoned and contained in some
sort of magical incantation we last left
off in part two with him being taken
into Hell by Lilith but I don't know
about you guys but I don't really get a
hel vibe from this place it looks more
like the dungeons of the witch Academy
and this red robe on him looks eerily
similar to Sabrina's cape which
coincidentally she wears at the
beginning of the video remember the main
focus of the season is Sabrina trying to
save Nick so this could be a shot of her
attempting to save him but how she got
him out of how we don't exactly know and
it looks like this season will feature a
lot of magical rituals here we see
prudence and Ambrose partaking in
something that looks pretty complicated
with some skull and bones at the
foreground and some creepy doll figure
prudence ended the season wanting to
find her father Faustus Blackwood and so
my guess is this ritual has something to
do with this she even cuts herself
pouring blood over a map if that's not
enough evidence for you a map where we
can make out the word Shetland
the Shetland Islands are a group of
islands in northern Scotland and the
surname black
is said to originate from Scotland
Harvey Roz and Theo have started their
own band because the aspect ratio
changes here you can bet this is a real
clip from the season and not an ad in
for the music video trailer now things
start to get grim we have a bunch of
scarecrows or perhaps corpses lining the
path for what appears to be Theo Sabrina
Roz and Harvey this could take place in
the real world but come on who needs
that many scarecrows plus the fog gave
me flashbacks to when Sabrina had to
save Harvey from limbo but if I were to
hazard a guess they're venturing off to
hell in search of Nick ah now we get
some cool shots of hell high society and
the three wise demons the arrival of
these demons last chapter signaled the
arrival of the Antichrist much like how
the arrival of the three wise men
signaled the arrival of Christ they do
not like the idea of Sabrina becoming
Lucifer's bride since she's half mortal
and they see that as beneath them they
will likely do whatever it takes to
ensure she never sits on the throne
which may mean stopping her from saving
Nick now we get this brief shot of
Lucifer here and an even quicker shot of
him tackling Nick this likely is
symbolic of the struggle going on in
Nick's body between himself and Lucifer
expect to see more of this back and
forth in the season in all hail Lilith
Queen of Hell wearing her crown of bones
now here's our first shot of Zelda and
Hilda outside what appears to be the
Academy's Zelda is now High Priestess
and their white outfits suggests some
type of ritual or ceremony they're
standing in front of an odd group of
people some of them wearing masks said
Doran with wood according to Deadline
and mysterious carnival rolls into town
run by pagans looking to resurrect an
ancient evil this is likely them here's
a shot showing off Lilith in the
gorgeous set design with stained glass
depicting various events in Hell's
history this is followed by Zelda in
front of some chalkboards which appear
to show schematics for the acheron
configuration if you remember back last
season they tried to imprison Lucifer in
the Acheron but it didn't work perhaps
they've found a new way to solve this
problem here we have the O running
towards one of these scarecrows which
since it appears to be someone close to
him and judging by his tattered shirt I
think this is probably his Uncle Jesse
prudence and Ambrose continue their
adventure and I can't help but get a bye
you swap house type of vibe here leading
me to believe prudence might be looking
into voodoo or some other type of dark
magic in a request which makes sense
since the actress here portrays a woman
by the name of mambo Marie described as
a gorgeous voodoo priestess who will
help them track down Blackwood ah here
we have Aunt Hilda looking up at the
moon and in the background you can see
other students in their white outfits
arranged in a circle on the ground so
this is obviously some sort of ritual
probably to stop those pagans but also
seeing that she's fixated on the moon
there's a little tiny chance I'm
wondering if it has anything to do with
her love last season dr. Cerberus here
we have Sabrina and Ambrose overlooking
a passed-out Nick as she pours blood
over him my best guess is that this is
one of her first attempts to save him
but it won't work we have Lilith on this
creepy ass throne and our first shot of
this guy
Caliban a prince of Hell sculpted from
the clay from the city of pandemonium
according to my sources with Lucifer
gone there is a battle for control over
who reigns over hell and this Caliban
guy sees his opportunity to rule and
judging by this shot here many of the
established hell elite prefer him rather
than Sabrina or Lilith a bloody Sabrina
slaps Caliban and the others are like oh
[ __ ] so expect a bigger showdown between
these two that's it for this trailer
breakdown I hope you'll like and
subscribe as I'll be coming out with an
entire season breakdown at day after the
seasons release on January 25th leave a
comment below on your theories for the
season and be sure to follow me on
twitter at think story y team until next
time remember daddy loves you very much